- Good morning, everybody.
Hopefully, you can hear me okay.
It is a little bit loud in here.
You can ask me to speak up if you need to.
Welcome.
If somebody had told me,
I don't know, three or four years ago
that would be standing on a stage
at the AWS conference
talking about one of the
largest market opportunities
that I've seen in my
14, 15 years at Oracle,
I would've thought you were crazy.
But here we are, and it's tremendous.
My name is Doug Palmer.
I am Group Vice President
for Oracle's Data Platform
Sales organization
servicing the largest healthcare
and life sciences companies
in the US.
And by healthcare, we mean
the largest providers,
payers, pharma life sciences
and med distribution companies.
And by data platform, we mean our on-prem,
our cloud, our hardware environment,
and our licensed business in the US.
Now, I'm gonna talk a little
bit about healthcare today,
but I'm also gonna focus
really specifically
on the partnership that is Oracle and AWS
that probably a lot of
folks did not see coming
quite a few years ago,
and how it's unlocked a huge
opportunity for our customers
to capitalize on the massive data estate
that lives and breathes
in Oracle Databases
all over the world today.
But I do wanna start
with the common problem
that we see in almost every sector
within the healthcare space.
Over the last five decades,
whether it's from mainframe to
the client server, internet,
mobility, big data, all
the way into cloud and AI,
while the technology is modernized,
we have created massive amounts of data
and application silos
across the organizations.
Now, I see this in the
largest healthcare providers
in the US
with thousands of applications
introducing tremendous cost and overhead
in a sector that today is
challenged with margin,
margin challenges, cost optimization,
and resource constraints across the board.
Now, this same 50 years
of computing paradigm
has led to this
application and data sprawl
has also inhibited us from capitalizing
on the market momentum of AI.
AI models require data,
and they require good data.
And this application challenge
has caused a ton of sprawl,
a ton of data movement,
and also introduced
significant security risks,
governance challenges, regardless
of the sector you're in,
whether it's the largest
pharmaceutical organizations,
payers, or life sciences.
Now, the data opportunity in healthcare,
for examples, is tremendous.
In the top left, it is to gain
visibility across all data
for understanding things
like population health,
improving patient outcomes,
improving physician's life experience.
If you look to the right,
more data sources equal better
decision-making and value.
That is true, but it's also
presented a massive challenge.
If I look at the vertical integration
of the provider space
from the primary care
to the specialists to the
acute and the ambulatory,
it's a challenge to
understand a patient journey
when there's data in
silos across everywhere.
But the opportunity to
focus on patient centricity
and to provide a better patient experience
and a better continuum of care
is an opportunity that we are working on,
and data is at the center of all that.
If we look at connecting
the data value chain
and automating decisions,
interoperability is one of the
most important things for us
in the healthcare space.
Whether we're talking about the providers,
whether we're looking at the payers
or the policy makers
to help focus on improving
prior authorization,
claims adjudication,
real-time claims adjudication,
and the data is at the heart of it all.
And then on the left,
unifying data structures for
lowering risk operations.
We see this in the
provider space tremendously
of trying to understand
cost and containment,
physician cost, supply chain costs,
and again, data not being
capitalized on the best today
given the sprawl across the board.
Now, I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what is this Database@AWS offering
that Oracle has brought to the market.
And I'm gonna look at it from the lens
of really four or five common
scenarios that we've seen
as we've deployed this in production
for many customers already today.
The first is modernizing from
IaaS to Database services.
Over the last five or 10 years,
a lot of our customers
have deployed Oracle
Database on native IaaS.
Now, that was the right choice at the time
because it was the only offering
and customers rely on Oracle Database.
However, now we're seeing
an opportunity to leverage
Oracle Database@AWS native services
to improve scalability, security,
maintenance and operations,
and reduce costs.
And I'll talk about some
examples in a little bit.
The second one, and there's
really two in this category,
it's reuniting apps and
Database in the cloud.
Many of my customers
have massive Oracle
environments sitting on-prem,
yet they have chosen AWS
as their hyperscaler of choice
and made the decision to
separate the app stack
from the Database and leave it on-prem.
Now, what that's introduced
is latency challenges,
customer not having a good experience,
and so we're seeing a lot of
our customers now capitalizing
on their hyperscaler of
choice, in this case AWS,
and marry the Database in the
cloud with the application
to improve performance for
the end user experience.
At the same time,
I have loads of customers
running very large Oracle
workloads on-prem today:
claims and policy administration systems,
custom applications, large data warehouses
that rely on high availability,
security, performance,
and in many cases are running
our incredible technology
that is Exadata
and our real application clusters
to maintain the high availability needed.
Now, we're unlocking that
ability for our customers
to migrate those
applications and workloads
directly into a
Database@AWS native service.
It's tremendous.
I can tell you, I've had customers,
very large payers across the US
that have been asking for
this capability for years,
and here we are, 2025 having delivered it.
The fourth is really the
building applications
with Oracle in the hyperscaler dev stack.
Again, with the Oracle Database,
our converged 26ai Database
native capabilities
across Vector, JSON, Graph
in a single database environment
can now deploy that natively within AWS
directly from the AWS Console,
but capitalize on the
advanced AWS services
for doing things like AI,
agentic systems and whatever you needed.
Obviously, that goes along
with enabling enterprise AI.
Today, we have a habit and a market
of moving data to the AI.
Oracle has a firm belief
in doing the opposite,
is bring AI to the data.
So allowing our customers to
deploy natively within AWS
and bring the large
language models to the data
versus moving the data to the models.
Now, we haven't,
this isn't a new service,
I guess I could say.
Oracle pioneered the concept
of multi-cloud starting in 2019
when we announced the Azure
Oracle OCI Interconnect.
And it really was, I mean, it
was monumental in the market
when Larry and Satya got up
on stage and talked about it,
and it was really to
kind of connect clouds
to give our customers the best choice.
Since then, we've announced
Database @ services
with Azure, with GCP,
and most recently with AWS
with two regions live,
East 1 and West 2,
and many more,
I think it's up to now 20 more regions
planned in the future.
So in five short years,
Oracle has delivered the power
of choice to our customers.
I can tell you from my perspective,
having been here for quite some time,
when I can sit down in
front of senior executives
at my customers and say,
"Where do you want to
deploy the Oracle Database?
You tell me.
We're providing you the opportunity
to deploy it wherever you like."
And for me, especially
in the life sciences
and the payer space,
the opportunity for us to partner with AWS
is just absolutely tremendous,
probably the largest market
opportunity I've seen
in many, many years.
Now, trusted for more than 48 years,
Oracle Database is synonymous
with enterprise software.
Now, founded in 1977
as Software Development Laboratories,
if didn't know that,
by Larry Ellison.
Our first customer was the
Central Intelligence Agency.
So we were founded
and born out of the intelligence community
with a rich history predicated
on security, trust, scale.
Most large enterprises today
and entities around the world,
both government and otherwise,
rely on Oracle Database
as the trusted data management service
for the majority of
the world's data today.
And over the last decade,
many of our customers,
most of our customers,
have invested tremendous
amounts of dollars
in other hyperscalers.
Now, today, with Oracle Database@AWS
and Azure and Google,
our customers have the choice
to deploy that wherever they want to.
It's the best of both worlds,
and it's truly one of the
best things we've released in,
I can't tell you.
So, what about some of the benefits?
As I talked about, the Oracle
Database has a reputation
second to none and only getting better.
Oracle Database delivered at AWS
is by far the fastest,
most performant, most
scalable and secure way
to deliver your Oracle Database.
Performance and availability at peak.
Maximum performance with purpose-built
database infrastructure.
Let me be clear, we have
deployed our hardware
inside of the AWS data centers,
which is a unique thing.
Minimize latency with
local database access
directly from the hyperscaler services.
No different than calling
another database service in AWS Console
versus calling Oracle's
Database@AWS service,
either our full Exadata Cloud Service
or our Autonomous Service,
which we'll talk a little bit about later.
So achieve extreme availability,
cut maintenance and downtime,
reduce your operational costs
by leveraging native cloud
service of the AWS from Oracle.
Reduce complexity,
use fewer database platforms
and require less integration.
Again, the 26ai concept
of our converged database
being able to handle
native vector capabilities,
Graph, JSON, Spatial within
one database environment.
Simplify management operations.
You work directly within the AWS Console,
no need to punch out to another console,
it is directly within the AWS Console.
And create a standardized
set of skill sets
for the Oracle Database.
We see our customers
that have unlimited
license agreements with us
capitalize on this tremendously
by having ability to deploy
at scale how they need to.
Reduce risks,
security, continue to identify
and remediate threats,
reduce chance of human errors.
We deployed the Autonomous Database
to be able to self-secure,
self-repair, auto-scale on your own
to reduce human intervention,
which obviously reduces security risks.
And finally, use your
choice of AI and analytics.
Migrate data to the Oracle Database@,
and securely access your data
within the latest GenAI
services and AI capabilities,
many new ones which
have been announced here
at re:Invent today.
Run the analytics of your choice
and create and run DevOps
and microservices how you want.
Now, just gonna drill into a
little bit of where we are,
the top scenarios that we see.
To this day, many of my customers
are running Oracle Databases
natively on IaaS services.
Now, again, at the time,
great choice,
but if you could do it over today,
would you make the same choice?
And 90% of the conversations I have,
the answer is no.
There's a maintenance overhead,
there's database sprawl,
it's costly to maintain.
Using the Database@ services with AWS,
up to 99.995 SLAs,
fully managed database infrastructure,
fully managed autonomous,
and we're seeing incredible opportunities
for up to 40:1 database consolidation,
given the performant nature
of our services deployed within AWS.
Second scenario,
again, reuniting apps and
database in the cloud.
I have customers in the healthcare space
that have massive data warehouses,
they have deployed on-prem
and wanna leverage some of that data
to provide customer-facing applications.
Performance has never been ideal.
Now we have the opportunity
to leverage those AWS native services
with the Oracle Database,
removing latency,
improving the customer experience,
and a consistent collaborative support
as well as net new
development opportunities.
Finally, building new applications
with Oracle Database@AWS.
Today, a lot of the applications
that we see our customers build
may not meet performance,
availability or security needs,
especially if you're
developing applications
that require a multitude
of databases and data types
to support that application.
It introduces challenges,
multiple skillset requirements,
overhead of additional
services for AI and analytics,
different security paradigms
for different databases,
post after,
enterprise grade performance at scale,
high availability, security
in a single database that
supports all data types:
JSON, Vector, Graph, Spatial,
unstructured, semi-structured,
structured data in a single environment
built-in GenAI and machine
learning capabilities
to allow us to bring AI to the data
versus the opposite moving.
Again, Oracle Database@,
the best of both worlds.
Enterprise grade data management services,
highly available, fully automated,
performant, agile, built-in security
combined with the most
widely adopted cloud today,
leveraging services like EC2, EKS, S3,
SageMaker, Bedrock, Amazon Q,
or any of the native services
that have been announced today.
So, as we kind of wrap up here
in the next two or three minutes,
it's really why Oracle Database@AWS?
And I can tell you
again in my 15-year career,
it is probably the easiest conversation
that I can go have with our customers.
I can provide full Oracle capabilities
in our purpose-built
performance and security
on our Exadata XM11 hardware
deployed inside of the AWS data centers.
I can deploy RAC.
All of my customers that
run RAC over the years
have been asking, "Why can't I deploy RAC
and have the high availability
I need inside of AWS?"
Now, we can.
It's been a while, but
we finally delivered it.
Migrate your on-premise
workloads easily and quickly.
There's another advantage,
de-risking projects by migrating workloads
directly from Oracle Databases on-prem
directly to an Oracle
Database running in AWS.
It's a seamless migration.
We're doing these and
have many, many customers
live in production today already.
Second, low latency.
I get this question a lot,
so I do have to clarify.
It runs within the AWS data center
to enable latency-sensitive applications
to perform at their best.
The same connectivity latency
for Oracle Database@AWS
and their first-party AWS
services in AWS data centers,
no difference.
A seamless experience.
In order to deliver a service like this,
we had to provide a seamless
experience for our customers.
Provision and deploy
directly from the AWS
Management Console or API.
A collaborative support
for supporting the customers in need.
And purchasing it directly
through the AWS Marketplace.
Again, a unique opportunity for us
to capitalize on commits
already made with AWS,
burned down the commercials
leveraging Database@ services
and unlocking databases today
that are often sitting on-prem
to get them to the cloud.
And then we have native AWS services
like zero-ETL integration
between Oracle Database services
and AWS Analytics services.
And a connected enterprise
in Oracle Database with EC2
and the rest of the services.
Now, as I wrap here,
got one minute left.
If you want more information about this,
it is certainly a huge opportunity for us.
We'd love to talk to you.
One, we've got a booth over in the corner,
happy to answer questions.
And two, we have a litany
of these opportunities
coming across the US,
in Chicago, Atlanta, Boston,
Houston, Austin, Seattle,
to come talk to our teams
about the opportunity
and how we can unlock this for you
and your other customers.
So with that, I really
appreciate everyone's time.
I'd be happy to also dive in
if anybody has more questions
about healthcare specifically
versus just the Database@AWS service.
Oracle has a massive commitment
to healthcare, as you know.
We are committed to help driving
the health ecosystem across it,
so I'd be happy to talk
more specifics about that
if you have any questions.
But certainly happy to talk
about this incredible service
and partnership that we have with AWS
if there's anything you'd like.
With that, thank you very much.
Appreciate your time today.